benvenuti su arido stories a grandissima
richiesta secondo episodio di scary ti
serve lo scorso video di scherzi alla
maestra scheri teaser ha raggiunto i 30
mila mi piace e vi avevo promesso che se
quel video vessero aggiunto di 30 mila
mi piace avremmo fatto la seconda parte
se anche questo video raggiunge i 40
mila mi piace ci sarà anche una terza
parte
stavo pensando uno scherzo in cui poter
mettere lo slime in testa alla maestra
scrittice quindi lasciate un bel mi
piace qua se non avete visto l'episodio
presidente andate a vederlo dopo questo
video e alla fine di questo video
dovrete votare qual è lo scherzo che vi
ha divertito di più nel sondaggio che è
a destra o sinistra nomi regole sono
semplicissime io dovrò fare un sacco di
scherzi alla maestra scheri teacher come
nel videogioco o devo essere presa se
vengo presa anche solo una volta ho
perso il gioco e non posso fare più
scherzi alla maestra nel frattempo ho
già organizzato il pegno scherzo
berlino sto facendo divertire
non posso essere presa neanche una volta
altrimenti non posso più fare iscriversi
per le note accadute attacca la attacca
la berlino ok sto andando via
o no sta tornando ad attaccare a berlino
bravo berlino mi difende sempre tanta
acqua o una cosa che userò per lo
scherzo messo in dimenticate di almeno
cosa importantissima se non vi stupite
ancora su instagram andati a seguirmi il
nome anita stories e se volete potete
anche seguirmi su tik tok il nome è
sempre anita stories non preparato per
il primo scrivere vi faccio vedere come
funziona allora avrete capito che è un
topo finto insomma berlino che fa ancora
da kabul che ne tiziano molto bene lo
istruito molto bene io alleato fedele
allora praticamente basta caricarla
avete visto
no no no no no berlino non è per te ok
il fiume per te devo usarlo per lo
scherzo ascheri teacher non posso non
posso darlo a te se berlino lo prende
non lo mollerà più lo disintegrerà con i
suoi denti
quindi devo stare attenta che merlino
non prenda questo tipo finto perché
altrimenti non posso fare lo scherzo
alla maestra comunque andiamo ora a
cercarlo e mettiamo questo tipo finto
vediamo come reagisce non arrivano
perché è uno strano ho iniziato a
cercare spiriti c'era la maestra ma non
la trovo forse è sceso al piano di sotto
ho sentito prima che voleva a cucinare
qualcosa oggi forse una torta mi è
venuta in mente un'idea per il secondo
scherzo ma prima
iniziamo con il primo al terzo
innanzitutto devo riuscire a un essere
presa per il primo scherzo altrimenti
non può trovare il secondo
berlino non vorrei capire mi sono
nascosta qua si è seduta proviamo a
caricare il topo non come faccio come lo
si faccia uscire merlino giocare in
giardino o portato merlino a giocare in
giardino così non rischio che mangi
questa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]
ragazzi questa volta c'è mancato poco
purtroppo il topo si incastra tutto il
team amato sotto e non potevo andare a
prendere quindi scritti sarà iniziato
rincorrermi pittura super divertente si
stava spaventando un sacco ma non vi
preoccupate perché o con un'altra idea
per il secondo scherzo alle ore fra poco
lei farà merenda noi osserveremo con
cosa fai merenda e tre motivi aggiungere
qualcosa ad assumere ma siete pronti
[Musica]
merenda
avete visto sta mangiando yogurt per 30
andiamo in cucina e vediamo cos'altro di
amore poi dovremmo distrarla però ok
ragazzi sono in cucina ora vedo se trovo
qualcosa in frigo che assomiglia allo
yogurt ma si è un po schivo potrei
mettere del ketchup e rosso se ne
accorgerebbe subito ci vuole qualcosa
che abbia un colore molto simile allo
yogurt rime per edel maionese in effetti
è molto simile agli yogurt
potrei anche mettere della mostarda
stand up è solo indecisa se mettere la
mostarda o la maionese mista che metto
tutte noi rimostrare super attenti a non
farci scoprire la tv per distrarla
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bousquet ragazzi un altro scherzo
riuscito è stato super divertente anche
questo c'è la sua pazza così impara
intrufolarsi ogni volta in casa mia
loro tutti quei pazzi ma ormai lo sapete
insomma comunque un'idea fantastica per
il terzo scherzo so che lei voleva
preparare qualcosa tipo una torta o dei
biscotti quindi avrà sicuramente una
ciotola con dello zucchero o della
farina o dello scotch sotto la foto la
con la farina lo zucchero
così quando lei andrà a prenderla se non
tirerà tutto in forza se avete capito
bene ma insomma ora vedrete cosa intendo
dire non vedo l'ora di vedere la sua
faccia ricoperta di farina o di zucchero
scrivete pure nei commenti vostri
consigli di scherzi da fare se iscritti
per tornerà intrufolarsi in casa mia
scrivete pure i vostri consigli con gli
altri scherzi potrei farlo di questo
scherzo è molto più difficile da
preparare quindi devo fare supera tempo
ma ho già tutto quello che vi serve
quindi andiamo e vediamo se sta già
preparando la torta oi biscotti non
posso sta cucinando
piccola sta preparando qualcosa mai
impegno dello scorcio di succede di un
disco
viene appiccicata e ora aspettiamo che
rientri e vediamo cosa succede
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
spiriti search ho preso è stato super
divertente
l'ultimo scritto è stato veramente
fantastico visto come aveva tutta la
farina in faccia ma anche nei vestiti
spero che questo servirà a farle capire
che non deve più intrufolarsi in casa
mia senza permesso mi raccomando
lasciate un bel mi piace per vedere un
terzo episodio votate pure il vostro
scherzo preferito e se volete rivedere
il primo episodio di scary teacher
cliccate qui se invece volete vedere la
nuova serie prova non aver paura
cliccate qui se volete vedere tutti
trovarono trova il 23enne clicca qui
solo a vedere qualche video con berlino
clicca qui
cliccate la casellina che preferisce
buona visione
ciao
[Musica]